the following is a conversation with
Michael Kern's he's a professor at the
University of Pennsylvania and a
co-author of the new book ethical
algorithm that is the focus of much of
this conversation it includes
algorithmic fairness bias privacy and
ethics in general but that is just one
of many fields that Michael's a
world-class researcher in some of which
would touch on quickly including
learning theory or the theoretical
foundation of machine learning game
theory quantitative finance
computational social science and much
more but on a personal note when I was
an undergrad early on I worked with
Michael on an algorithmic trading
project in competition that he led
that's when I first fell in love with
algorithmic game theory while most of my
research life has been a machine
learning human robot interaction the
systematic way that game theory reveals
the beautiful structure and our
competitive and cooperating world of
humans has been a continued and
inspiration to me so for that and other
things
I'm deeply thankful to Michael and
really enjoyed having this conversation
again
in person after so many years this is
the artificial intelligence podcast if
you enjoy it subscribe on YouTube give
it five stars on Apple podcasts
supported on patreon or simply connect
with me on Twitter at lex Friedman's
both Fri D ma n this episode is
supported by an amazing podcast called
pessimists archive Jason the host the
show reached out to me looking to
support this podcast and so I listened
to it to check it out and I listened I
mean I went through it Netflix binge
style at least 5 episodes in a row it's
not one of my favorite podcast and I
think it should be one of the top
podcasts in the world frankly it's a
history show about why people resist new
things each episode looks at a moment in
history when something new was
introduced something that today we think
of as commonplace like recorded music
umbrellas bicycles cars chests coffee
the elevator and the show explores why
freaked everyone out the latest episode
on mirrors and vanity still stays with
they think about vanity in the modern
day of the Twitter world that's the
fascinating thing about the show is that
stuff that happened long ago especially
in terms of our fear of new things
repeats itself in the modern day and so
has many lessons for us to think about
in terms of human psychology and the
role of Technology in our society anyway
you should subscribe but listen the
pessimist archive I highly recommended
and now here's my conversation with
Michael Kern's you mentioned reading
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas in high
school and having more or a bit more of
a literary mind so what books
non-technical non computer science would
you say had the biggest impact on your
life either intellectually or
emotionally you've dug deep into my
history I see deep yeah I think well my
favorite novel is Infinite Jest by David
Foster Wallace which actually
coincidentally much of it takes place in
the halls of buildings right around us
here at MIT so that certainly had a big
influence on me and as you noticed like
when I was in high school I actually
Stephen started college as an English
major so was very influenced by sort of
badge genre of journalism at the time
and thought I wanted to be a writer and
then realized that an English major
teaches you to read but it doesn't teach
you how to write and then I became
interested in math and computer science
instead well in your new book ethical
algorithm you kind of sneak up from a
algorithmic perspective on these deep
profound philosophical questions of
fairness of privacy in thinking about
these topics how often do you return to
that literary mind that either you had
yeah I'd like to claim there was a
deeper connection but but there you know
I think both Aaron and I kind of came at
these topics first and foremost from a
technical angle I mean you know I'm kind
of consider myself primarily and
originally a machine learning researcher
and I think as we just watched like the
rest of the society the field
technically advanced and then quickly on
the heels of that kind of the the
buzzkill of all
the antisocial behavior by algorithms
just kind of realized there was an
opportunity for us to do something about
it from a research perspective you know
a more to the point in your question I
mean I do have an uncle who is literally
a moral philosopher and so in the early
days of our technical work on fairness
topics I would occasionally you know run
ideas behind him so I mean I remembered
an early email I sent to him in which I
said like oh you know here's a specific
definition of algorithmic fairness that
we think is some sort of variants of
Rawls II in fairness what do you think
and I thought I was asking a yes-or-no
question and I got back there kind of
classical philosophers responsive well
it depends if you look at it this way
then you might conclude this and that's
when I realized that there was a real
kind of rift between the ways
philosophers and others had thought
about things like fairness you know from
sort of a humanitarian perspective and
the way that you needed to think about
it as a computer scientist if you were
going to kind of implement actual
algorithmic solutions but I would say
the algorithmic solutions take care of
some of the low-hanging fruit sort of
the problem is a lot of algorithms when
they don't consider fairness they are
just terribly unfair and when they don't
consider privacy they're terribly they
violate privacy sort of algorithmic
approach fixes big problems but there's
though you get when you start pushing
into the gray area that's when you start
getting into this philosophy of what it
means to be fair that's starting from
Plato what what is justice kind of
questions yeah I think that's right and
I mean I would even not go as far as you
want to say that that sort of the
algorithmic work in these areas is
solving like the biggest problems and
you know we discussed in the book the
fact that really we are there's a sense
in which we're kind of looking where the
light is in that you know for example if
police are racist in who they decide to
stop and frisk and that goes into the
data there's sort of no undoing that
Downs
by kind of clever algorithmic methods
and I think especially in fairness I
mean I think less so in privacy where we
feel like the community kind of really
has settled on the right definition
which is differential privacy if you
just look at the algorithmic fairness
literature already you can see it's
gonna be much more of a mess and you
know you've got these theorems saying
here are three entirely reasonable
desirable notions of fairness and you
know here's a proof that you cannot
simultaneously have all three of them so
I think we know that algorithmic
fairness compared to algorithmic privacy
is gonna be kind of a harder problem and
it will have to revisit I think things
that have been thought about by you know
many generations of scholars before us
so it's very early days for fairness I
think so before we get into the details
of differential privacy and then the
fairness side
I mean linger on the philosophy but do
you think most people are fundamentally
good or do most of us have both the
capacity for good and evil within us I
mean I'm an optimist I tend to think
that most people are good and want to do
to do right and that deviations from
that or you know kind of usually due to
circumstance to people being bad at
heart with people with power are people
at the heads of governments people at
the heads of companies people at the
heads of maybe so financial power
markets do you think the distribution
there is also most people are good and
have good intent yeah I do I mean my
statement wasn't qualified to people not
in positions of power I mean I think
what happens in a lot of the you know
the the cliche about absolute power
corrupts absolutely I mean you know I
think even short of that you know having
spent a lot of time on Wall Street and
also in arenas very very different from
Wall Street like academia you know one
of the things I think I've benefited
from by moving between two very
different worlds is you you become aware
that you know these were
it's kind of developed their own social
norms and they develop their own
rationales for you know behavior for
instance that might look unusual to
outsiders but when you're in that world
it doesn't feel unusual at all and I
think this is true of a lot of you know
professional cultures for instance and
and you know so then you're maybe
slippery slope is too strong of a word
but you know you're in some world where
you're mainly around other people with
the same kind of viewpoints and training
and worldview as you and I think that's
more of a source of you know kind of
abuses of power then sort of you know
there being good people and evil people
and and it's somehow the evil people are
the ones that somehow rise to power
that's really interesting so it's the
within the social norms constructed by
that particular group of people you're
all trying to do good but because it's a
group you might be you might drift into
something that for the broader
population it does not align with the
values of society that kind of that's
the word yeah I mean or nothing you
drift but even the things that don't
make sense to the outside world don't
seem unusual to you so it's not sort of
like a good or a bad thing but you know
like so for instance you know on on in
the world of finance right there's a lot
of complicated types of activity that if
you are not immersed in that world you
cannot see why the purpose of that you
know that activity exists at all it just
seems like you know completely useless
and people just like you know pushing
money around and when you're in that
world right you're you and you learn
more you your view does become more
nuanced right you realize okay there is
actually a function to this activity and
force in some cases you would conclude
that actually if magically we could
eradicate this activity tomorrow it
would come back because it actually is
like serving some useful purpose it's
just a useful purpose that's very
difficult for outsiders to see and so I
think you know lots of professional work
environments or cultures as I might put
it kind of have these social norms that
you know domain
sense to the outside world academia is
the same right I mean lots of people
look at academia and say you know what
the hell are all of you people doing
why are you paid so much in some cases
at taxpayer expenses to do you know to
publish papers and military reads you
know but when you're in that world you
come to see the value for it and but
even though you might not be able to
explain it to you know the person in the
street alright and in the case of the
financial sector tools like credit might
not make sense to people like is it's a
good example of something that does seem
to pop up and be useful or or just the
power of markets and just in general
capitalism yeah and Finance I think the
primary example I would give is leverage
right so being allowed to borrow to sort
of use ten times as much money as you've
actually borrowed right so so that's an
example of something that before I had
any experience in financial markets I
might have looked at and said well what
is the purpose of that that just seems
very dangerous and it is dangerous and
it has proven dangerous but you know if
the fact of the matter is that you know
sort of on some particular time scale
you are holding positions that are you
know very unlikely to you know loo you
know they're you know that your value at
risk their variance is like 1 or 5
percent then it kind of makes sense that
you would be allowed to use a little bit
more than you have because you have you
know some confidence that you're not
going to lose it all in a single day
now of course when that happens we've
seen what happens you know not not too
long ago but but you know but the idea
that it serves no useful economic
purpose under any circumstances is
definitely not true we'll return to the
other side of the coast Silicon Valley
and the problems there as we talk about
privacy as we talk about fairness at the
high level and I'll ask some sort of
basic questions with the hope to get at
the fundamental nature of reality but
from a very high level what is an
ethical algorithm so I can say that an
algorithm has a running time of using
Big Oil notation
and login I can say that a machine
learning algorithm classified cat versus
dog with 97% accuracy do you think there
will one day be a way to measure sort of
in the same compelling way as the big ol
notation of this algorithm is 97%
ethical first of all many rif for a
second on your specific and login
examples so because early in the book
when we're just kind of trying to
describe algorithms period we say like
ok you know what's an example of an
algorithm or an algorithmic problem
first of all I could sorting right yeah
I'm a bunch of index cards with numbers
on them and you want to sort them and we
describe you know an algorithm that
sweeps all the way through finds the the
smallest number puts it at the front
then sweeps through again finds the
second smallest number so we make the
point that this is an algorithm and it's
also a bad algorithm in the sense that
you know it's quadratic rather than n
log n which we know is optimal for
sorting and we make the point that sort
of like you know so even within the
confines of a very precisely specified
problem there's you know there might be
many many different algorithms for the
same problem with different properties
like some might be faster in terms of
running time some I use less memory some
might have you know better distributed
implementations and and so the point is
is that already we're used to you know
in computer science thinking about
trade-offs between different types of
quantities and resources and there being
you know better and worse algorithms and
and our book is about that part of
algorithmic ethics that we know how to
kind of put on that same kind of
quantitative footing right now so you
know just to say something that our book
is not about our book is not about kind
of broad fuzzy notions of fairness it's
about very specific notions of fairness
there's more than one of them there are
tensions between them right but if you
pick one of them you can do something
akin to saying
this algorithm is 97% ethical you can
say for instance the you know for this
lending model the false rejection rate
on black people and white people is
within 3 percent right so we might call
that to a 97% ethical algorithm in a
100% ethical algorithm would mean that
that difference is 0% in that case
fairness is specified when two groups
however they're defined are given to you
that's right so the and and then you can
sort of mathematically start describing
the algorithm but nevertheless the the
part where the two groups are given to
you I mean unlike running time you know
we don't in a computer science talk
about how fast an algorithm feels like
when it runs true we measure an ethical
starts getting into feelings so for
example an algorithm runs you know if it
runs in the background it doesn't
disturb the performance of my system
it'll feel nice I'll be okay with it but
if it overloads the system will feel
unpleasant so in that same way ethics
there's a feeling of how socially
acceptable it is how does it represent
the moral standards of our society today
so in that sense and sorry to linger on
that for some high low philosophical
question is do you have a sense we'll be
able to measure how ethical and
algorithm is first of all I didn't
certainly didn't mean to give the
impression that you can kind of measure
you know memory speed trade-offs you
know and and that there's a complete you
know mapping from that on to kind of
fairness for instance or ethics and and
accuracy for example in the type of
fairness definitions that are largely
the objects of study today and starting
to be deployed you as the user of the
definitions you need to make some hard
decisions before you even get to the
point of designing fair algorithms one
of them for instance is deciding who it
is that you're worried about protecting
who you're worried about being harmed by
for instance
some notion of discrimination or
unfairness and then you need to also
decide what constitutes harm so for
instance in a lending application maybe
you decide that you know falsely
rejecting a credit worthy individual you
know sort of a false negative is the
real harm and that false positives ie
people that are not credit worthy or are
not going to repay your loan to get a
loan you might think of them as lucky
and so that's not a harm although it's
not clear that if you are don't have the
means to repay a loan that being given a
loan is not also a harm so you know you
know the literature is sort of so far
quite limited in that you sort of need
to say who do you want to protect and
what would constitute harm to that group
and when you ask questions like will
algorithms feel ethical one way in which
they won't under the definitions that
I'm describing is if you know if you are
an individual who is falsely denied
alone incorrectly denied a loan all of
these definitions basically say like
well you know your compensation is the
knowledge that we are we are also
falsely denying loans to other people
you know other groups at the same rate
that we're doing it's to you and and you
know there and so there is actually this
interesting even technical tension in
the field right now between these sort
of group notions of fairness and notions
of fairness that might actually feel
like real fairness to individuals right
they they might really feel like their
particular interests are being protected
or thought about by the algorithm rather
than just you know the groups that they
happen to be members of is there
parallels to the big o-notation of
worst-case analysis so is it important
to looking at the worst violation of
fairness for an individual is important
to minimize that one individual so like
worst case analysis is that something
you think about or I mean I think we're
not even at the point where we can
sensibly think about that so first of
all you know we're talking here both
about fairness applied at the group
level which is
a relatively weak thing but it's better
than nothing and also the more ambitious
thing of trying to give some individual
promises but even that doesn't
incorporate I think something that
you're hinting at here is what a chime
I'll call subjective fairness right
right so a lot of the definitions I mean
all of the definitions in the
algorithmic fairness literature are what
I would kind of call received wisdom
definitions it's sort of you know
somebody like me sits around and things
like okay you know I think here's a
technical definition of fairness that I
think people should want or that they
should you know think of as some notion
of fairness maybe not the only one maybe
not the best one maybe not the last one
but we really actually don't know from a
subjective standpoint like what people
really think is fair there's you know
we've we've just started doing a little
bit of work in in our group that
actually doing kind of human subject
experiments in which we you know ask
people about you know we ask them
questions about fairness we survey them
we you know we show them pairs of
individuals in let's say a criminal
recidivism prediction setting and we ask
them do you think these two individuals
should be treated the same as a matter
of fairness and to my knowledge there's
not a large literature in which ordinary
people are asked about you know they
they have sort of notions of their
subjective fairness elicited from them
it's mainly you know kind of scholars
who think about fairness no right and
I'm making up their own definitions and
I think I think this needs to change
actually for many social norms not just
for fairness right so there's a lot of
discussion these days in the AI
community about interpretable AI or
understandable AI and as far as I can
tell everybody agrees that deep learning
or at least the outputs of deep learning
are not very understandable and people
might agree that sparse linear models
with integer coefficients are more
understandable but nobody's really asked
people you know there's very little
literature on you know sort of showing
people models and asking them do they
understand what the model is doing and I
think that in all these topics as these
fields mature we need to start doing
more behavioral work yeah which is so
one of my deep passions of psychology
and I always thought computer scientists
will be the the best future
psychologists in a sense that data is
especially in this modern world the data
is a really powerful way to understand
and study human behavior and you've
explored that with your game theory side
of work as well yeah I'd like to think
that what you say is true about computer
scientists and psychology from my own
limited wandering into human subject
experiments we have a great deal to
learn not just computer science but AI
and machine learning more specifically I
kind of think of as imperialist research
communities in that you know kind of
like physicists in an earlier generation
computer scientists kind of don't think
of any scientific topic as off limits to
them they will like freely wander into
areas that others have been thinking
about for decades or longer and you know
we usually tend to embarrass ourselves
yes in those efforts for for some amount
of time like you know I think
reinforcement learning is a good example
right so a lot of the early work in
reinforcement learning I have complete
sympathy for the control theorist that
looked at this and said like okay you
are reinventing stuff that we've known
since like the 40s right but you know in
my view eventually this sort of you know
computer scientists have made
significant contributions to that field
even though we kind of embarrassed
ourselves for the first decade so I
think if computer scientists are gonna
start engaging in kind of psychology
human subjects type of research we
should expect to be embarrassing
ourselves for a good ten years or so and
then hope that it turns out as well as
you know some other areas that we've
waded into so you kind of mentioned this
just the linger on the idea of an
ethical algorithm of idea of group
sort of group thinking an individual
thinking and we're struggling that
there's one of the amazing things about
algorithms and your book and just this
field of study is it gets us to ask like
forcing machines converting these ideas
into algorithms is forcing us to ask
questions of ourselves as a human
civilization so there's a lot of people
now in public discourse doing sort of
group thinking thinking like there's
particular sets of groups that we don't
want to discriminate against and so on
and then there is individuals sort of in
the individual life stories the
struggles they went through and so on
now like in philosophy it's easier to do
group thinking because you don't you
know it's very hard to think about
individuals there's so much variability
but with data you can start to actually
say you know what group thinking is too
crude you're actually doing more
discrimination by thinking in terms of
groups and individuals can you linger on
that kind of idea of group versus
individual and ethics and and is it good
to continue thinking in terms of groups
in in algorithms so let me start by
answering a very good high level
question with a slightly narrow
technical response which is these group
definitions of fairness like here's a
few groups like different racial groups
may be gender groups may be age
what-have-you and let's make sure that
you know from none of these groups do we
you know have a false negative rate
which is much higher than any other one
of these groups okay so these are kind
of classic group aggregate notions of
fairness and you know but at the end of
the day an individual you can think of
as a combination of all of their
attributes right they're a member of a
racial group they're they have a gender
they have an age you know and many other
you know demographic properties that are
not biological but that you know are are
still you know very strong determinants
of outcome and personality in the light
so one I think useful spectrum is to
sort of think about that array between
the group and this
individual and to realize that in some
ways asking for fairness at the
individual level is to sort of ask for
group fairness simultaneously for all
possible combinations of groups so in
particular so in particular yes
you know if I build a predictive model
that meets some definition of fairness
by race by gender by age by
what-have-you marginally to get a
slightly technical sort of independently
I shouldn't expect that model to not to
discriminate against disabled Hispanic
women over age 55 making less than fifty
thousand dollars a year or annually even
though I might have protected each one
of those attributes marginally so the
optimization actually that's a
fascinating way to put it
so you're just optimizing the one way to
achieve the optimizing fairness for
individuals just to add more and more
definitions of groups at each and it's
right along so you know at the end of
the day we could think of all of
ourselves as groups of size one because
eventually there's some attribute that
separates you from me and everybody from
everybody else in the world okay and so
it is possible to put you know these
incredibly coarse ways of thinking about
their nests and these very very
individualistic specific ways on a
common scale and you know one of the
things we've worked on from a research
perspective is you know so we sort of
know how to you know we in relative
terms we know how to provide fairness
guarantees at the coarsest end of the
scale we don't know how to provide kind
of sensible tractable realistic fairness
guarantees at the individual level but
maybe we could start creeping towards
that by dealing with more you know
refined subgroups I mean we we gave a
name to this phenomenon where you know
you protect you you you enforce some
definite definition of fairness for a
bunch of marginal attributes or features
but then you find yourself
discriminating against a combination of
them we call that fairness
gerrymandering because like political
gerrymandering you know you're giving
some guarantee at the aggregate level
yes
but that when you kind of look in a more
granular way at what's going on you
realize that you're achieving that
aggregate guarantee by sort of favoring
some groups in discriminating against
other ones and and so there are you know
it's early days but there are
algorithmic approaches that let you
start creep and creeping towards that
you know individual end of the spectrum
does there need to be human input in the
form of weighing the value of the
importance of each kind of group so for
example is it is it like so gender say
crudely speaking male and female and
then different races are we as humans
supposed to put value on saying gender
is 0.6 and racist 0.4 in terms of in the
big optimization of achieving fairness
is that kind of what humans I mean most
of you know I mean of course you know I
don't need to tell you that of course
technically one could incorporate such
weights if you wanted to into a
definition of fairness you know fairness
is an interesting topic in that having
worked in in the book being about both
fairness privacy and many other social
norms fairness of course is a much much
more loaded topic so privacy I mean
people want privacy people don't like
violations of privacy violations of
privacy cause damage angst and and bad
publicity for the companies that are
victims of them but sort of everybody
agrees more data privacy would be better
than less data privacy and and you don't
have these somehow the discussions of
fairness don't become politicized along
other dimensions like race and about
gender and you know you know whether we
you and you know did you quickly find
yourselves kind of revisiting topics
that have been kind of unresolved
forever like affirmative
action right sort of you know like why
are you protecting and some people will
say why are you protecting this
particular racial group and and others
will say what we need to do that as a
matter of retribution other people will
say it's a matter of economic
opportunity and I don't know which of
you know whether any of these are the
right answers but you sort of fairness
is sort of special in that as soon as
you start talking about it you
inevitably have to participate in
debates about fair to whom at what
expense to who else I mean even in
criminal justice right um you know where
people talk about fairness in criminal
sentencing or you know predicting
failures to appear or making parole
decisions or the like they will you know
they'll point out that well these
definitions of fairness are all about
fairness for the criminals and what
about fairness for the victims right so
when I basically say something like well
the the false incarceration rate for
black people and white people needs to
be roughly the same you know there's no
mention of potential victims of
criminals in such a fairness definition
and that's the realm of public discourse
I just listened to two people listening
intelligent squares debates us edition
just had a debate they have this
structure we have a old Oxford style or
whatever they're called debates those
two versus two and they talked about
affirmative action and it was the is
incredibly interesting that it's still
there's really good points on every side
of this issue which is fascinating to
listen yeah yeah I agree and so it's
it's interesting to be a researcher
trying to do for the most part technical
algorithmic work but Aaron and I both
quickly learned you cannot do that and
then go out and talk about and expect
people to take it seriously if you're
unwilling to engage in these broader
debates that are
entirely extra algorithmic right there
they're not about you know algorithms
and making algorithms better they're
sort of you know as you said sort of
like what should society be protecting
in the first place when you discuss the
fairness an algorithm that uh that
achieves fairness whether in the
constraints and the objective function
there's an immediate kind of analysis
you can perform which is saying if you
care about fairness in gender this is
the amount that you have to pay for in
terms of the performance of the system
like do you is there a role for the
statements like that in a table and a
paper or do you want to really not touch
that like you know we want to touch that
and we do touch it so I mean just just
again to make sure I'm not promising
your your viewers more than we know how
to provide but if you pick a definition
of fairness like I'm worried about
gender discrimination and you pick a
notion of harm like false rejection for
a loan for example and you give me a
model I can definitely first of all go
on at that model it's easy for me to go
you know from data to kind of say like
okay your false rejection rate on women
is this much higher than it is on men
okay but you know once you also put the
fairness in to your objective function I
mean I think the table that you're
talking about is you know what we would
call the Pareto curve right you can
literally trace out and we give examples
of such plots on real datasets in the
book you have two axes on the x-axis is
your error on the y-axis is unfairness
by whatever you know if it's like the
disparity between false rejection rates
between two groups and you know your
algorithm now has a knob that basically
says how strongly do I want to enforce
fairness and the less unfairly you know
we you know if the two axes are err and
unfairness we'd like to be at 0-0
we'd like to zero error and zero fair
unfairness simultaneously anybody who
works in machine learning knows that
you're generally not going to get to
zero error period without any fairness
constrain
whatsoever so that's that that's not
gonna happen but in general you know
you'll get this you'll get some kind of
convex curve that specifies the
numerical trade-off you face you know if
I want to go from 17 percent error down
to 16 percent error what will be the
increase in unfairness that I've
experienced as a result of that and and
so this curve kind of specifies the you
know kind of undaunted models models
that are off that curve are you know can
be strictly improved in one or both
dimensions you can you know either make
the error better or the unfairness
better or both and I think our view is
that not only are are these objects
these Pareto curves
you know there's efficient frontiers as
you might call them not only are they
valuable scientific objects I actually
think that they in the near term might
need to be the interface between
researchers working in the field and and
stakeholders and given problems so you
know you could really imagine telling a
criminal jurisdiction look if you're
concerned about racial fairness but
you're also concerned about accuracy you
want to you know you want to release on
parole people that are not going to
recommit a violent crime and you don't
want to release the ones who are so you
know that's accuracy but if you also
care about those you know the mistakes
you make not being disproportionately on
one racial group or another you can you
can show this curve I'm hoping that in
the near future it'll be possible to
explain these curves to non-technical
people that have that are the ones that
have to make the decision where do we
want to be on this curve like what are
the relative merits or value of having
lower error versus lower unfairness you
know that's not something computer
scientists should be deciding for
society right that you know the people
in the field so to speak the
policymakers the regulator's that's who
should be making these decisions
but I think and hope that they can be
made to understand that these trade-offs
generally exist and that you need to
pick a point and like and ignoring the
trade-off you know you're implicitly
picking a point anyway right right you
just don't know it and you're not
admitting it it's just a link out on the
point of trade-offs I think that's a
really important thing to sort of think
about so you think when we start to
optimize for fairness there's almost
always in most system going to be
trade-offs can you like what's the
trade-off between just to clarify
they've been some sort of technical
terms thrown around but a sort of a
perfectly fair world why is that
why will somebody be upset about that
the specific trade-off I talked about
just in order to make things very
concrete was between numerical error and
some numerical measure of unfairness in
what is numerical error in the case of
just likes a predictive error like you
know the probability or frequency with
which you release somebody on parole who
then goes on to recommit a violent crime
or keep incarcerated somebody who would
not have recommitted a violent crime so
in case of awarding somebody parole or
giving somebody Perl or letting them out
on parole you don't want them to
recommit a crime so it's your system
failed in prediction if they happen to
do a crime okay so that's the performer
that's one axis right and what's the
fairness axis so then the fairness axis
might be the difference between racial
groups in the kind of false false
positive predictions namely people that
I kept incarcerated
predicting that they would recommit a
violent-crime when in fact they wouldn't
have right and the the unfairness of
that just to linger it and allow me to
in eloquently to try to sort of describe
why that's unfair
why unfairness is there the the
unfairness you want to get rid of is the
in the judges mind the bias of having
being brought up to society the slight
racial bias the racism that exists in
the society you want to remove that from
the system another way that's been
debated is equality of opportunity
versus equality of outcome and there's a
weird dance there that's really
difficult to get right
and we don't as what the firm ative
action is exploring that space right and
then we this also quickly you know
bleeds into questions like well maybe if
one group really does recommit crimes at
a higher rate the reason for that is
that at some earlier point in the
pipeline or earlier in their lives they
didn't receive the same resources that
the other group did right and that and
so you know there's always in in kind of
fairness discussions the possibility
that the the real injustice came earlier
right earlier in this individuals life
earlier in this group's history etc etc
and and so a lot of the fairness
discussion is almost the goal is for it
to be a corrective mechanism to account
for the injustice earlier in life by
some definitions of fairness or some
theories of fairness yeah others would
say like look it's it's you know it's
not to correct that injustice it's just
to kind of level the playing field right
now and Nanyan coarser a falsely
incarcerate more people of one group
than another group but I mean do you
think just it might be helpful just to
demystify a little bit about the diff
bias or unfairness can come into
algorithms especially in the machine
learning era right and you know I think
many of your viewers have probably heard
these examples before
but you know let's say I'm building a
face recognition system right and so I'm
you know kind of gathering lots of
images of faces and you know trying to
train the system to you know recognize
new faces of those individuals from
training on you know a training set of
those faces of individuals and you know
it shouldn't surprise anybody or
certainly not anybody in the field of
machine learning if my training dataset
was primarily white males and I'm
training that mmm the model to maximize
the overall accuracy on my training data
set that you know the model can reduce
its air or most by getting things right
on the white males that constitute the
majority of the data set even if that
means that on other groups they will be
less accurate okay now there's a bunch
of ways you could think about addressing
this one is to deliberately put into the
objective of the algorithm not to not to
optimize the air or at the expense of
this discrimination and then you're kind
of back in the land of these kind of
two-dimensional numerical trade-offs a
valid counter-argument is to say like
well no you don't have to there's no you
know the the notion of the tension
between air and Acuras here is a false
one you could instead just go out and
get much more data on these other groups
that are in the minority and you know
equalize your dataset or you could train
a separate model on those subgroups and
you know have multiple models the point
I think we would you know we try to make
in the book is that those things have
cost too right going out and gathering
more data on groups that are relatively
rare compared to your plurality or more
majority group that you know it may not
cost you in the accuracy of the model
but it's gonna cost you know it's gonna
cost the company developing this model
more money to develop that and it has
also cost more money to build separate
predictive models and to implement and
deploy them so even if you can find a
way to avoid the tension between error
and accuracy
training a model you might push the cost
somewhere else like money like
development time research time and alike
there are fundamentally difficult
philosophical questions in fairness and
we live in a very divisive political
climate outrage culture there is uh all
right folks on 4chan trolls there is
social justice warriors on Twitter
there is very divisive outraged folks
and all sides of every kind of system
how do you how do we as engineers build
ethical algorithms in such divisive
culture do you think they could be
disjoint the human has to inject your
values and then you can optimize over
those values but in our times when when
you start actually applying these
systems things get a little bit
challenging for the public discourse how
do you think we can proceed yeah I mean
for the most part in the book you know a
point that we try to take some pains to
make is that we don't view ourselves or
people like us as being in the position
of deciding for society what the right
social norms are what the right
definitions of fairness are our main
point is to just show that if society or
the relevant stakeholders in a
particular domain can come to agreement
on those sorts of things there's a way
of encoding that into algorithms in many
cases not in all cases one other
misconception though hopefully we
definitely dispel is sometimes people
read the title of the book and I think
not unnaturally fear that what we're
suggesting is that the algorithms
themselves should decide what those
social norms are and develop their own
notions of fairness and privacy or
ethics and we're definitely not
suggesting that the title of the book is
ethical algorithm by the way and they
didn't think of that interpretation of
the title that's interesting yeah yeah I
mean especially these days were people
are you know concerned about the robots
becoming our overlords the idea that the
robots would also like sort of develop
their own social norms is you know
just one step away from that but I do
think you know obviously despite
disclaimer that people like us shouldn't
be making those decisions for society we
are kind of living in a world where in
many ways computer scientists have made
some decisions that have fundamentally
changed the nature of our society and
democracy and in sort of civil discourse
and deliberation in ways that I think
most people generally feel are bad these
days right so but they had to make so if
we look at people at the heads of
companies and so on they had to make
those decisions right there has to be
decisions so there's there's two options
either you kind of put your head in the
sand and don't think about these things
and just let they all go and do what it
does or you make decisions about what
you value you know open injecting moral
values into that with look I don't never
mean to be an apologist for the tech
industry but I think it's it's a little
bit too far to sort of say that explicit
decisions were made about these things
so let's for instance take social media
platforms right so like many inventions
in technology and computer science a lot
of these platforms that we now use
regularly kind of started as curiosities
right I remember when things like
Facebook came out in its predecessors
like Friendster which nobody even
remembers now the people people really
wonder like what why would anybody want
to spend time doing that you know what I
mean even even the web when it first
came out when it wasn't populated with
much content and it was largely kind of
hobbyists building their own kind of
ramshackle websites a lot of people
looked at this this is like what is the
purpose of this thing why is this
interesting who would want to do this
and so even things like Facebook and
Twitter yes
technical decisions were made by
engineers by scientists by executives in
the design of those platforms but you
know I don't I don't think 10 years ago
anyone anticipated that those platforms
for instance might kind of acquire undo
you know influence on political
discourse or on the outcomes of election
and I think the scrutiny that these
companies are getting now is entirely
appropriate but I think it's a little
too harsh to kind of look at history and
sort of say like oh you should have been
able to anticipate that this would
happen with your platform and in this
sort of gaming chapter of the book one
of the points we're making is that you
know these platforms right they don't
operate in isolation so like that unlike
the other topics we're discussing like
fairness and privacy like those are
really cases where algorithms can
operate on your data and make decisions
about you and you're not even aware of
it okay things like Facebook and Twitter
these are you know these are these are
systems right these are social systems
and their evolution even their technical
evolution because machine learning is
involved is driven in no small part by
the behavior of the users themselves and
how the users decide to adopt them and
how to use them and so you know you know
I'm kind of like who really knew that
the you know in until until we saw it
happen who knew that these things might
be able to influence the outcome of
elections who knew that you know they
might polarize political discourse
because of the ability to you know
decide who you interact with on the
platform and also with the platform
naturally using machine learning to
optimize for your own interest that they
would further isolate us from each other
and you know like feed us all basically
just the stuff that we already agreed
with and I think it you know we've come
to that outcome I think largely but I
think it's something that we all learned
together including the companies as
these things happen you asked like well
are there algorithmic remedies to these
kinds of things and again these are big
problems that are not going to be solved
with you know somebody going in and
changing a few lines of code somewhere
in a social media platform but I do
think in many ways there are there are
definitely ways of making things better
I mean like an obvious recommendation
that we we make at some point in the
book is like look you know to the extent
that we think that machine learning
applied for person
purposes in things like newsfeed you
know or other platforms has led to
polarization and intolerance of opposing
viewpoints as you know right these these
algorithms have models right and they
kind of place people in some kind of
metric space and and they place content
in that space and they sort of know the
extent to which I have an affinity for a
particular type of content and by the
same token they also probably have that
that same model probably gives you a
good idea of the stuff I'm likely to
violently disagree whether it be
offended by okay so you know in this
case there really is some nod you could
tune it says like instead of showing
people only what they like and what they
want let's show them some stuff that we
think that they don't like or that's a
little bit further away and you could
even imagine users being able to control
this you know just like a everybody gets
a slider and that slider says like you
know how much stuff do you want to see
that's kind of you know you might
disagree with or is at least further
from your interests I can it's almost
like an exploration button so just get
your intuition do you think engagement
so like you staying on the platform you
because thing engaged do you think
fairness ideas of fairness won't emerge
like how bad is it to just optimize for
engagement do you think we'll run into
big trouble if we're just optimizing for
how much you love the platform well I
mean optimizing for engagement kind of
got us where we are
so do you one have faith that it's
possible to do better and two if it is
how do we do better I mean it's
definitely possible to do different
right and again you know it's not as if
I think that doing something different
than optimizing for engagement won't
cost these companies in real ways
including revenue and profitability
potentially short-term at least yeah in
the short term right and again you know
if I worked at these companies I'm sure
that it
it would have seemed like the most
natural thing in the world also to want
to optimize engagement right and that's
good for users in some sense you want
them to be you know vested in the
platform and enjoying it and finding it
useful interesting and or productive but
you know my point is is that the idea
that there is that it's sort of out of
their hands as you said or that there's
nothing to do about it
Never Say Never but that strikes me as
implausible as a machine-learning person
right I mean these companies are driven
by machine learning and this
optimization of engagement is
essentially driven by machine learning
right it's driven by not just machine
learning but you know very very
large-scale a be experimentation where
you gonna have tweaked some element of
the user interface or tweaked some
component of an algorithm or tweak some
component or feature of your
click-through prediction model and my
point is is that anytime you know how to
optimize for something you'll you you
know by def almost by definition that
solution tells you how not to optimize
for it or to do something different
engagement can be measured so sort of
optimizing for sort of minimizing
divisiveness or maximizing intellectual
growth over the lifetime of a human
being very difficult to measure that
that's right so I'm not I'm not claiming
that doing something different will
immediately make it apparent that this
is a good thing for society and in
particular I mean ethical one way of
thinking about where we are on some of
these social media platforms is it you
know it kind of feels a bit like we're
in a bad equilibrium right that these
systems are helping us all kind of
optimize something myopically and
selfishly for ourselves and of course
from an individual standpoint at any
given moment like what why would I want
to see things in my newsfeed that I
found irrelevant offensive or you know
or the like okay but you know maybe by
all of us you know having these
platforms myopically optimized in our
interests we have reached a collective
outcome as a society that were unhappy
with in different ways
let's say with respect to things like
you know political discourse and
tolerance of opposing viewpoints and if
Mark Zuckerberg gave you a call and said
I'm thinking of taking a sabbatical
could you run Facebook for me for four
six months what would you how I think no
thanks would be the first response but
there are many aspects of being the head
of the the entire company there are kind
of entirely exogenous to many of the
things that we're discussing here yes
and so I don't really think I would need
to be CEO at Facebook to kind of
implement the you know more limited set
of solutions that I might imagine but I
think one one concrete thing they could
do is they could experiment with letting
people who chose to to see more stuff in
their newsfeed that is not entirely kind
of chosen to optimize for their
particular interests beliefs etc so the
the kind of thing is I could speak to
YouTube but I think Facebook probably
does something similar is they're quite
effective at automatically finding what
sorts of groups you belong to not based
on race or gender so on but based on the
kind of stuff you enjoy watching and it
gets a YouTube serve it's a it's a
difficult thing for Facebook or YouTube
to then say well you know what we're
going to show you something from a very
different cluster even though we believe
algorithmically you're unlikely to enjoy
that thing so if that's a weird jump to
make there has to be a human like at the
very top of that system that says well
that will be long-term healthy for you
that's more than an algorithmic decision
or or that same person could say that'll
be long-term healthy for the platform
the platform for the platform's
influence on society outside of the
platform right and they you know it's
easy for me to sit here and say these
things yes but conceptually I do not
think that these are kind of totally or
should they shouldn't be kind of
completely alien ideas right there
you know we you could try things like
this and it wouldn't be you know we
wouldn't have to invent entirely new
science to do it because if we're all
already embedded in some metric space
and there's a notion of distance between
you and me and every other every piece
of content then you know we know exactly
you know the same model that tells you
know that dictates how to make me really
happy also tells how to make me as
unhappy as possible as well right the
the focus in your book and algorithmic
fairness research today in general is on
machine learning like we said is data
but and just even the entire AI feel
right now is captivated with machine
learning with deep learning do you think
ideas in symbolic AI or totally other
kinds of approaches are interesting
useful in the space have some promising
ideas in terms of fairness I haven't
thought about that question specifically
in the context of fairness I definitely
would agree with that statement in the
large right I mean I am you know one of
many machine learning researchers who do
believe that the great successes that
have been shown in machine learning
recently are great successes but they're
on a pretty narrow set of tasks I mean I
don't I don't think were kind of notably
closer to general artificial
intelligence now than we were when I
started my career I mean there's been
progress and and I do think that we are
kind of as a community maybe looking a
bit where the light is but the light is
shining pretty bright there right now
and we're finding a lot of stuff so I
don't want to like argue with the
progress that's been made in areas like
deep learning for example this touches
another sort of related thing that you
mentioned and that people might
misinterpret from the title of your book
ethical algorithm is it possible for the
algorithm to automate some of those
decisions sort of higher-level decisions
of what kind of like what what should be
fair what should be fair the more you
know about a field the more aware you
are of its limitations and so I'm pretty
leery of sort of trying you know there's
there's so much we don't all we
don't know in fairness even when were
the ones picking the fairness
definitions and you know comparing
alternatives and thinking about the
tensions between different definitions
that the idea of kind of letting the
algorithm start exploring as well I
definitely think you know this is a much
narrower statement I definitely think
the kind of algorithmic auditing for
different types of unfairness right so
like in this gerrymandering example
where I might want to prevent not just
discrimination against very broad
categories but against combinations of
broad categories you know you quickly
get to a point where there's a lot of a
lot of categories there's a lot of
combinations of n features and you know
you can use algorithmic techniques to
sort of try to find the subgroups on
which you're discriminating the most and
try to fix that that's actually kind of
the form of one of the algorithms we
developed for this fairness
gerrymandering problem but I'm you know
partly because of our technology our
sort of our scientific ignorance on
these topics right now and also partly
just because these topics are so loaded
emotionally for people that I just don't
see the value I mean again Never Say
Never but I just don't think we're at a
moment where it's a great time for
computer scientists to be rolling out
the idea like hey you know you know not
only have we kind of figured fairness
out but you know we think the algorithm
should start deciding what's fair or
giving input on that decision I just
don't laugh it's like the the
cost-benefit analysis to the field of
kind of going there right now it just
doesn't seem worth it to me that said I
should say that I think computer
scientists should be more
philosophically like should enrich their
thinking about these kinds of things I
think it's been too often used as an
excuse for roboticists or cantatas
vehicles for example to not think about
the human factor or psychology or safety
in the same way like computer science
design algorithms that be sort of using
is an excuse and I think it's time for
basically everybody to become computer
scientists
I was about to agree with everything you
said except that last point I think that
the other way of looking at is that I
think computer scientists you know and
and and
many of us are but we need to wait out
into the world more right I mean just
the the influence that computer science
and therefore computer scientists have
had on society at large just like has
exponentially magnified in the last 10
or 20 years or so and you know you know
before when we were just thinking
tinkering around amongst ourselves and
it didn't matter that much there was no
need for sort of computer scientists to
be citizens of the world more broadly
and I think those days need to be over
very very fast and I'm not saying
everybody needs to do it but to me like
the right way of doing it is to not to
sort of think that everybody else is
going to become a computer scientist but
you know I think you know people are
becoming more sophisticated about
computer science even laypeople yeah you
know though I think one of the reasons
we decided to write this book as we
thought
10 years ago I wouldn't have tried this
because I I just didn't think that sort
of people's awareness of algorithms and
machine learning you know the general
population would have been high and I
mean would you would have had to first
you know write one of the many books
kind of just explicate alais audience
first now I think we're at the point
where like lots of people without any
technical training at all know enough
about algorithms machine learning that
you can start getting to these nuances
of things like ethical algorithms I
think we agree that there needs to be
much more mixing but I think I think a
lot of the onus of that mixing needs to
be on the computer science community
yeah so just to linger on the
disagreement because I do disagree with
you on the point that I think if you're
a biologist if you're a chemist if you
are an MBA business person all of those
things you can like if you learn to
program and not only program if you
learn to do machine learning if you know
energy data science you immediately
become much more powerful the kinds of
things you can do and therefore
literature like the library Sciences
like so you're speaking I think deaf I
think it holds true well you're saying
for the next two years but
long term if you're interested to me if
you're interested in philosophy you
should learn to program because then you
can scrape data you can and study what
people are thinking about on Twitter and
then start making those awful
conclusions about the meaning of life
right I just I just feel like the access
to data the digitization of whatever
problem you're trying to solve is a
fundamentally change what it means to be
a computer scientist I mean computer
scientists in 20 30 years will go back
to being donald knuth style theoretical
computer science and everybody would be
doing basically they kind of exploring
the kinds of ideas the exploring in your
book it won't be a computer sighs yeah
yeah I mean I don't think I disagree not
but I think that that trend of more and
more people and more and more
disciplines adopting ideas from computer
science learning how to code I think
that that trend seems firmly underway I
mean you know like an interesting
digressive question along these lines is
maybe in 50 years
there won't be computer science
departments anymore because the field
will just sort of be ambient in all of
the different disciplines and you know
people will look back and you know
having a computer science department
will look like having an electricity
department or something that's like you
know everybody uses this it's just out
there I mean I do think there will
always be that kind of canoe style core
- yeah but it's not an implausible
half that we kind of get to the point
where the academic discipline of
computer science becomes somewhat
marginalized because of its very success
in kind of infiltrating all of science
and society and the humanities etc what
is differential privacy or more broadly
algorithmic privacy algorithmic privacy
more broadly is just the study or the
notion of privacy definitions or norms
being encoded inside of algorithms and
so you know I think we count among
this body of work just you know the
literature and practice of things like
data anonymization which we kind of at
the beginning of our discussion of
privacy say like okay this is this is
sort of a notion of algorithmic privacy
it kind of tells you you know something
to go do with data but but you know our
view is that it's and I think this is
now you know quite widespread that it's
you know despite the fact that those
notions of anonymization kind of redact
the in coarsening are the most widely
adopted technical solutions for data
privacy they are like deeply
fundamentally flawed and so you know to
your first question what is differential
privacy differential privacy seems to be
a much much better notion of privacy
that kind of avoids a lot of the
weaknesses of anonymization notions well
while still letting us do useful stuff
with data
what's anonymization of data so by
anonymous a ssin i'm you know kind of
referring to techniques like i have a
database the rows of that database are
let's say individual people's medical
records okay and i want to let people
use that data maybe i want to let
researchers access that data to build
predictive models for some disease but
i'm worried that that will leak you know
sensitive information about specific
people's medical records so
anonymization broadly refers to the set
of techniques where i say like okay i'm
first gonna like like i'm gonna delete
the column with people's names I'm going
to not put you know so that would be
like a redaction right I'm just
redacting that information I am going to
take ages and I'm not gonna like say
your exact age I'm gonna say whether
you're you know zero to 10 10 to 20 20
to 30 I might put the first three digits
of your zip code but not the last two
etc etc and so the idea is that through
some series of operations like this on
the data I anonymize it you know another
term of art that's used is removing
personally identifiable information
and you know this is basically the most
common way of providing data privacy but
that's in a way that still lets people
access the some variant form of the data
so at a slightly broader picture as you
talk about what does the not
immunization mean when you have multiple
database like with a Netflix prize when
you can start combining stuff together
so this is exactly the problem with
these notions right is that notions of
Adana anonymization removing personally
identifying information the kind of
fundamental conceptual flaw is that you
know these definitions kind of pretend
as if the data set in question is the
only data set that exists in the world
or that ever will exist in the future
and of course things like the Netflix
prize and many many other examples since
the Netflix applies I think that was one
of the earliest ones though you know you
can redefine oh that were anonymized in
the data set by taking that anonymized
data set and combining with other
allegedly anonymized data sets and may
be publicly available information about
you for people who don't know the
Netflix prize was what was being
publicly released this data so the names
from those rows were removed but what
was released is the preference or the
ratings of what movies you like and you
don't like and from that combined with
other things I think foreign posts and
so on you can case it was specifically
the Internet Movie Database where where
lots of Netflix users publicly rate
their move you know their movie
preferences and so the anonymized data
in Netflix when kaneen and it's it's
just this phenomenon I think that we've
all come to realize in the last decade
or so is that just knowing a few
apparently irrelevant
innocuous things about you can often act
as a fingerprint like if I know you know
what what rating you gave to these 10
movies and the date on which you entered
these movies this is almost like a
fingerprint for you is the see of all
Netflix users there were just another
paper on this in science or nature of
about a month ago that you know kind of
18 attributes I mean
my favorite example of this this was
actually a paper from several years ago
now where it was shown that just from
your likes on Facebook just from the
taunt you know the things on which you
clicked on the thumbs up button on the
platform not using any information
demographic information nothing about
who your friends are just knowing the
content that you had liked was enough to
you know in the aggregate accurately
predict things like sexual orientation
drug and alcohol use whether you were
the childhood divorced parents so we
live in this era where you know even the
apparently irrelevant data that we offer
about ourselves on public platforms and
forums often unbeknownst to us more or
less acts as signature or you know
fingerprint and that if you can kind of
you know do a join between that kind of
data and allegedly anonymize data you
have real trouble so is there hope for
any kind of privacy in a world where a
few likes can can identify you so there
is differential privacy right what is
differential differential privacy
basically is a kind of alternate much
stronger notion of privacy than these
anonymization ideas and it you know it's
a technical definition but like the
spirit of it is we we compare to to
alternate worlds okay so let's suppose
I'm a researcher and I want to do you
know I there's a database of medical
records and one of them's yours and I
want to use that database of medical
records to build a predictive model for
some disease so based on people's
symptoms and test results and the like I
want to you know build a Probab you know
model predicting the probability that
people have disease so you know this is
the type of scientific research that we
would like to be allowed to continue and
in differential privacy you act ask a
very particular counterfactual question
we basically compare two alternatives
one is when I do this I build this model
on the database of medical records
including your
medical record and the other one is
where I do the same exercise with the
same database with just your medical
record removed so basically you know
it's two databases one with n records in
it and one with n minus one records in
it the N minus one records are the same
and the only one that's missing in the
second case is your medical record so
differential privacy basically says that
any harms that might come to you from
the analysis in which your data was
included are essentially nearly
identical to the harms that would have
come to you if the same analysis had
done been done without your medical
record included so in other words this
doesn't say that bad things cannot
happen to you as a result of data
analysis it just says that these bad
things were going to happen to you
already even if your data wasn't
included and to give a very concrete
example right you know um you know like
we discussed at some length the the
study that you know the in the 50s that
was done that created the that
established the link between smoking and
lung cancer and we make the point that
like well if your data was used in that
analysis and you know the world kind of
knew that you were a smoker because you
know there was no stigma associated with
smoking before that those findings real
harm might have come to you as a result
of that study that your data was
included in in particular your insurer
now might have a higher posterior belief
that you might have lung cancer and
raise your premiums so you've suffered
economic damage but the point is is that
if the same analysis been done without
with all the other n minus-1 medical
records and just yours missing the
outcome would have been the same your
your data was an idiosyncratic eleum
crucial to establishing the link between
smoking and lung cancer because the link
between smoking and lung cancer is like
a fact about the world that can be
discovered with any sufficiently large
database of medical records but that's a
very low value of harm yeah
so that's showing that very little harm
is done great but how what is the
mechanism of differential privacy so
that's the kind of beautiful statement
of it well what's the mechanism by which
privacy's preserve yeah so it's it's
basically by adding noise to
computations right so the basic idea is
that every differentially private
algorithm first of all or every good
differentially private album every
useful one is a probabilistic algorithm
so it doesn't on a given input if you
gave the algorithm the same input
multiple times it would give different
outputs each time from some distribution
and the way you achieve differential
privacy algorithmically is by kind of
carefully and tastefully adding noise to
a computation in the right places and
you know to give a very concrete example
if I want to compute the average of a
set of numbers right the non private way
of doing that is to take those numbers
and average them and release like a
numerically precise value for the
average okay in differential privacy you
wouldn't do that you would first compute
that average to numerical Precision's
and then you'd add some noise to it
right you'd add some kind of zero mean
you know gaussian or exponential noise
to it so that the actual value you
output is not the exact mean but it'll
be close to the mean but it'll be close
the noise the you add will sort of prove
that nobody can kind of reverse engineer
any particular value that went into the
average so noise noise is the Savior how
many algorithms can be aided by making
by adding noise yeah so I'm a relatively
recent member of the differential
privacy community my co-author Aaron
Roth is you know really one of the
founders of the field and has done a
great deal of work and I've learned a
tremendous amount working with him on it
growing up field already yeah but it's
now it's pretty mature but I must admit
the first time I saw the definition of
deferential privacy my reaction was like
well that is a clever definition and
it's really making very strong promises
and my you know you know at first saw
the definition
in much earlier days and my first
reaction was like well my worry about
this definition would be that it's a
great definition of privacy but that
it'll be so restrictive that we won't
really be able to use it like you know
we won't be able to do compute many
things in a differentially private way
so that that's one of the great
successes of the field I think isn't
showing that the opposite is true and
that you know most things that we know
how to compute absent any privacy
considerations can be computed in a
differentially private way so for
example pretty much all of statistics
and machine learning can be done
differentially privately so pick your
favorites machine learning algorithm
back propagation and neural networks you
know cart for decision trees support
vector machines boosting you name it as
well as classic hypothesis testing and
the like and statistics none of those
algorithms are differentially private in
their original form
all of them have modifications that add
noise to the computation in different
places in different ways that achieve
differential privacy so this really
means that to the extent that you know
we've become a you know a scientific
community very dependent on the use of
machine learning and statistical
modeling and data analysis we really do
have a path to kind of provide privacy
guarantees to those methods and and sort
of we can still you know enjoy the
benefits of kind of the data science era
while providing you know rather robust
privacy guarantees to individuals so
perhaps a a slightly crazy question but
if we take that the ideas of
differential privacy and take it to the
nature of truth that's being explored
currently so what's your most favorite
and least favorite food hmm
I'm not a real foodie so I'm a big fan
of spaghetti I forget it yeah on what
what do you really don't like umm I
really don't like cauliflower well I
love golf okay but is one way to protect
your preference for spaghetti by having
in
formation campaign bloggers and so on a
boat's saying that you like cauliflower
so like this kind of the same kind of
noise ideas I mean if you think of in
our politics today there's this idea of
Russia hacking our elections what's
meant there I believe is BOTS spreading
different kinds of information is that a
kind of privacy or is that too much of a
stretch no it's not a stretch I have not
seen those idea you know that is not a
technique that to my knowledge will
provide differential privacy but but to
give an example like one very specific
example about what you're discussing is
there was a very interesting project at
NYU I think led by a Helen missin bomb
there in which they basically built a
browser plugin that tried to essentially
obfuscate your Google searches so to the
extent that you're worried that Google
is using your searches to build you know
predictive models about you to decide
what ads to show you which they might
very reasonably want to do but if you
object to that they built this widget
you could plug in and basically whenever
you put in a query into Google it would
send that query to Google but in the
background all the time from your
browser
it would just be sending this torrent of
irrelevant queries to the search engine
so you know it's like a weed and chaff
thing so you know out of every thousand
queries let's say that Google was
receiving from your browser one of them
was one that you put in but the other
999 were not okay so it's the same kind
of idea kind of you know privacy by
obfuscation so I think that's an
interesting idea doesn't give you
differential privacy it's also I was
actually talking to somebody at one of
the large tech companies recently about
the fact that you know just this kind of
thing that there are some times when the
response to my data needs to be very
specific to my data right like I type
mountain biking into Google I want
results on mountain biking and I really
want Google to know that I typed in
biking I don't want noise adage to that
and so I think there's sort of maybe
even interesting technical questions
around notions of privacy that are
appropriate where you know it's not that
my date is part of some aggregate like
medical records and that we're trying to
discover important correlations and
facts about the world at large
but rather you know there's a service
that I really want to you know pay
attention to my specific data yet I
still want some kind of privacy
guarantee and I think these kind of
obfuscation ideas are sort of one way of
getting at that but maybe there are
others as well so where do you think
will land in this algorithm driven
society in terms of privacy so sort of
China like Chi Fuli describes you know
it's collecting a lot of data on its
citizens but in the best form it's
actually able to provide a lot of sort
of protects human rights and provide a
lot of amazing services and its worst
forms it can violate those human rights
and and limit services so what do you
think will land on so algorithms are
powerful when they use data so as a
society do you think we'll give over
more data is it possible to protect the
privacy of that data so I'm optimistic
about the possibility of you know
balancing the desire for individual
privacy and individual control of
privacy with kind of societally and
commercially beneficial uses of data not
unrelated to differential privacy or
suggestions that say like well
individuals should have control of their
data they should be able to limit the
uses of that data they should even you
know there's there's you know fledgling
discussions going on in research circles
about allowing people selective use of
their data and being compensated for it
and then you get to sort of very
interesting economic questions like
pricing right and one interesting idea
is that maybe differential privacy would
also you know be Bo a conceptual
framework in which you could talk about
the relative value of different people's
data like you know to demystify this a
little bit if I
front of build a predictive model for
some rare disease and I'm trying to you
I'm gonna use machine learning to do it
it's easy to get negative examples
because the disease is rare right but I
really want to have lots of people with
the disease in my data set okay
but but and so somehow those people's
data with respect to this application is
much more valuable to me than just like
the background population and so maybe
they should be compensated more for it
and so you know I think these are kind
of very very fledgling conceptual
questions that maybe will have kind of
technical thought on them sometime in
the coming years but but I do think well
you know to kind of get more directly
answer your question I think I'm
optimistic at this point from what I've
seen that we will land at some you know
better compromise than we're at right
now where again you know privacy
guarantees are a few far between and
weak and users have very very little
control and I'm optimistic that we'll
land in something that you know provides
better privacy overall and more
individual control of data and privacy
but you know I think to get there it's
again just like fairness it's not going
to be enough to propose algorithmic
solutions there's gonna have to be a
whole kind of regulatory legal process
that prods companies and other parties
to kind of adopt solutions and I think
you've mentioned the word control and I
think giving people control that's
something that people don't quite have
and a lot of these algorithms that's a
really interesting idea of giving them
control some of that is actually
literally an interface design question
sort of just enabling because I think
it's good for everybody to give users
control it's not it's not a it's almost
not a trade off except you have to hire
people that are good at interface design
yeah I mean the other thing that has to
be said right is that you know it's a
cliche but you know we who is the users
of many systems platforms and apps you
know we are the product we are not the
customer the customer our advertisers
and our data is the prod
okay so it's one thing to kind of
suggest more individual control of data
and privacy and uses but this you know
if this happens in sufficient degree it
will upend the entire economic model
that has supported the internet to date
and so some other economic model will
have to be you know will have to replace
it so the idea of markets you mentioned
by exposing the economic model to the
people they will then become a market
they can be participants in participants
in and and you know this isn't you know
this is not a weird idea right because
there are markets for data already it's
just that consumers are not participants
in there's like you know there's sort of
you know publishers and content
providers on one side that have
inventory and then they're advertised on
the others and you know you know Google
and Facebook are running you know
they're pretty much their entire revenue
stream is by running two-sided markets
between those parties right and so it's
not a crazy idea that there would be
like a three sided market or that you
know that on one side of the market or
the other we would have proxies
representing our interest it's not you
know it's not a crazy idea but it would
it it's not a crazy technical idea but
it would have pretty extreme economic
consequences speaking of markets a lot
of fascinating aspects of this world
arise not from individual humans but
from the interaction of human beings
you've done a lot of work in game theory
first can you say what is game theory
and how does help us model and study
yeah game theory of course let us give
credit where it's due they don't comes
from the economist first and foremost
but as I've mentioned before like you
know computer scientists never hesitate
to wander into other people's turf and
so there is now this 20 year old field
called algorithmic game theory but you
know game game theory first and foremost
is a mathematical framework for
reasoning about collective outcomes in
systems of interacting individuals you
know so you need at least two people to
get started in game theory and many
people are probably familiar with
prisoner's dilemma as kind of a classic
example of game theory and a classic
example where everybody looking out for
their own individual interests leads to
a collective outcome that's kind of
worse for everybody then what might be
possible if they cooperated for example
but cooperation is not an equilibrium in
prisoner's dilemma and so my work and
the field of algorithmic game theory
more generally in these areas kind of
looks at settings in which the number of
actors is potentially extraordinarily
large and their incentives might be
quite complicated and kind of hard to
model directly but you still want kind
of algorithmic ways of kind of
predicting what will happen or
influencing what will happen in the
design of platforms so what to you is
the most beautiful idea that you've
encountered in game theory there's a lot
of them I'm a big fan of the field I
mean you know I mean technical answers
to that of course would include Nash's
work just establishing that you know
there there's a competitive equilibrium
under very very general circumstances
which in many ways kind of put the field
on a firm conceptual footing because if
you don't have equilibria it's kind of
hard to ever reason about what might
happen since you know there's just no
stability so just the idea that
stability can emerge when there's
multiple or that it means not that it
will necessarily emerge just that it's
possible right it's like the existence
of equilibrium doesn't mean that sort of
natural iterative behavior will
necessarily lead to it in the real world
yeah maybe answering a slightly less
personally than you asked the question I
think within the field of algorithmic
game theory perhaps the single most
important
kind of technical contribution that's
been made is the real the the
realization between close connections
between machine learning and game theory
and in particular between game theory
and the branch of machine learning
that's known as no regret learning and
and this sort of provides a fray a very
general framework in which a bunch of
players interacting in a game or a
system each one kind of doing something
that's in their self-interest will
actually kind of reach an equilibrium
and actually reach an equilibrium in a
you know a pretty you know a rather you
know short amount of steps so you kind
of mentioned acting greedily can somehow
end up pretty good for everybody or
pretty bad or pretty bad it will end up
stable yeah right and and you know
stability or equilibrium by itself is
neither is not necessarily either a good
thing or a bad thing so what's the
connection between machine learning and
the ideas well if we kind of talked
about these ideas already in in kind of
a non-technical way which is maybe the
more interesting way of understanding
them first which is you know we have
many systems platforms and apps these
days that work really hard to use our
data and the data of everybody else on
the platform to selfishly optimize on
behalf of each user okay so you know let
me let me give what the the cleanest
example which is just driving apps
navigation apps like you know Google
Maps and ways where you know
miraculously compared to when I was
growing up at least you know the
objective would be the same when you
wanted to drive from point A to point B
spend the least time driving not
necessarily minimize the distance but
minimize the time right and when I was
growing up like the only resources you
had to do that were like maps in the car
which literally just told you what roads
were available and then you might have
like half hourly traffic reports just
about the major freeways but not about
side roads so you were pretty much on
your own and now we've
these apps you pull it out and you say I
want to go from point A to point B and
in response kind of to what everybody
else is doing if you like what all the
other players in this game are doing
right now here's the the you know the
the route that minimizes your driving
time so it is really kind of computing a
selfish best response for each of us in
response to what all of the rest of us
are doing at any given moment and so you
know I think it's quite fair to think of
these apps as driving or nudging us all
towards the competitive or Nash
equilibrium of that game now you might
ask like well that sounds great why is
that a bad thing
well you know it's it's known both in
theory and with some limited studies
from actual like traffic data that all
of us being in this competitive
equilibrium might cause our collective
driving time to be higher may be
significantly higher than it would be
under other solutions and then you have
to talk about what those other solutions
might be and what what the algorithms to
implement them are which we do discuss
in the kind of game theory chapter of
the book but but similarly you know on
social media platforms or on Amazon you
know all these algorithms that are
essentially trying to optimize our
behalf they're driving us in a
colloquial sense towards some kind of
competitive equilibrium and you know one
of the most important lessons of game
theory is that just because we're at
equilibrium doesn't mean that there's
not a solution in which some or maybe
even all of us might be better off and
then the connection to machine learning
of course is that in all these platforms
I've mentioned the optimization that
they're doing on our behalf is driven by
machine learning you know like
predicting where the traffic will be
predicting what products I'm gonna like
predicting what would make me happy in
my newsfeed now in terms of the
stability and the promise of that I have
to ask just out of curiosity how stable
are these mechanisms that you game
theories just The Economist's came up
with and we all know that economists
don't live in the real world just
kidding
sort of what's do
think when we look at the fact that we
haven't blown ourselves up from the from
a game theoretic concept of mutually
assured destruction what are the odds
that we destroy ourselves with nuclear
weapons as one example of a stable game
theoretic system just to prime your
viewers a little bit I mean I think
you're referring to the fact that game
theory was taken quite seriously back in
the 60s as a tool for reasoning about
kind of Soviet US nuclear armament
disarmed ative date on things like that
I'll be honest as huge of a fan as I am
of game theory and it's kind of rich
history it still surprises me that you
know you had people at the RAND
Corporation back in those days kind of
drawing up you know two by two tables
and one the row player is weekend oh the
US and the column player is Russia and
that they were taking seriously you know
you know I'm sure if I was there maybe
it wouldn't have seemed as as naive as
it does at the time you know seems to
have worked which is why it seems naive
well we're still here we're still here
in that sense yeah even though I kind of
laugh at those efforts they were more
sensible than than they would be now
right because there were sort of only
two nuclear powers at the time and you
didn't have to worry about deterring new
entrants and who was developing the
capacity and so we have many we have
this it's definitely a game with more
players now and more potential entrants
I'm not in general somebody who
advocates using kind of simple
mathematical models when the stakes are
as high as things like that and the
complexities are very political and
social but but we are still here so
you've worn many hats one of which the
one that first caused me to become a big
fan of your work many years ago is
algorithmic trading so I have to just
ask a question about this because you
have so much fascinating work there in
the 21st century would what role do you
think algorithms have in space of
trading investment in the financial
sector yeah
it's a good question I mean
in the time I've spent on Wall Street
and in finance you know I've seen a
clear progression and I think it's a
progression that kind of models the use
of algorithms and automation more
generally in society which is you know
the things that kind of get taken over
by the algos first are sort of the
things that computers are obviously
better at than people right so you know
so first of all there needed to be this
era of automation right we're just you
know financial exchanges became largely
electronic which then enabled the
possibility of you know trading becoming
more algorithmic because once you know
the exchanges are electronic an
algorithm can submit an order through an
API just as well as a human can do at a
monitor quickly it can read all the data
so yeah and so you know I think the the
places where algorithmic trading have
had the greatest inroads and had the
first inroads were in in kind of
execution problems kind of optimized
execution problems so what I mean by
that is at a large brokerage firm for
example one of the lines of business
might be on behalf of large
institutional clients taking you know
what we might consider difficult trade
so it's not like a mom-and-pop investor
saying I want to buy a hundred shares of
Microsoft it's a large hedge fund saying
you know I want to buy a very very large
stake in Apple and I want to do it over
the span of a day and it's such a large
volume that if you're not clever about
how you break that trade up not just
over time but over perhaps multiple
different electronic exchanges that all
let you trade Apple on their platform
you know you will you will move you'll
push prices around in a way that hurts
your your execution so you know this is
the kind of you know this is an
optimization problem this is a control
problem right and so machines are a
better we know how to design algorithms
you know that are better at that kind of
thing then a person is going to be able
to do because we can take volumes of
historical and real-time data to kind of
optimize the schedule with which we
trade and you know similarly high
frequency trading you know which is
closely related but not this
optimized execution where you're just
trying to spot very very temporary you
know miss pricings between exchanges or
within an asset itself or just predict
directional movement of a stock because
of the kind of very very low-level
granular buying and selling data in in
the exchange machines are good at this
kind of stuff it's kind of like the
mechanics of trading what about the can
machines do long terms of prediction
yeah so I think we are in an era where
you know clearly there have been some
very successful
you know quant hedge funds that are you
know in what we would traditionally call
you know still in this the stat ARB
regime like so you know stat are
referring to statistical arbitrage but
but for the purposes of this
conversation what it really means is
making directional predictions in asset
price movement or returns your
prediction about that directional
movement is good for you know you you
have a view that it's valid for some
period of time between a few seconds and
a few days and that's the amount of time
that you're gonna kind of get into the
position hold it and then hopefully be
right about the directional movement and
you know buy low and sell high as the
cliche goes so that is a you know kind
of a sweet spot I think for quant
trading and investing right now and has
been for some time when you really get
to kind of more warren buffett style
timescales right like you know my
cartoon of warren buffett is that you
know warren buffett sits and thinks what
the long-term value of Apple really
should be and he doesn't even look at
what Apple's doing today he just decides
you know yeah you know I think that this
was what its long-term value is and it's
far from that right now and so I'm gonna
buy some Apple or you know shorts and
Apple and I'm gonna I'm gonna sit on
that for 10 or 20 years okay so when
you're at that kind of time scale or
even more than just a few days all kinds
of other sources of risk and information
you know so now
are talking about holding things through
recessions and economic cycles wars can
break out so there you have to install a
human nature at 11:00 yeah and you need
to just be able to ingest many many more
sources of data that are on wildly
different timescales right so if I'm an
hft I'm a high-frequency trader like I
don't I don't I really my main source of
data is just the data from the exchanges
themselves about the activity in the
exchanges right and maybe I need to pay
you know I need to keep an eye on the
news right because you know that can
sudden cause sudden you know the the you
know CEO gets caught in a scandal or you
know gets run over by a bus or something
that can cause very sudden changes in
but you know I don't need to understand
economic cycles I don't need to
understand recessions I don't need to
worry about the political situation or
war breaking out in this part of the
world because you know all you need to
know is as long as that's not gonna
happen in the left next 500 milliseconds
then you know my models good when you
get to these longer timescales you
really have to worry about that kind of
stuff and people in the machine learning
community are starting to think about
this we held a we did we jointly
sponsored a workshop at 10:00 with the
Federal Reserve Bank of Philadelphia a
little more than a year ago on you know
I think the title is something like
machine learning for macroeconomic
prediction
you know macroeconomic referring
specifically to these longer timescales
and you know it was an interesting
conference but it you know my it left me
with greater confidence that we have a
long way to go to you know and so I
think that people that you know in the
grand scheme of things you know if
somebody asked me like well whose job on
Wall Street is safe from the bots I
think people that are at that longer you
know the time scale and have that
appetite for all the risks involved in
long term investing and that really need
kind of not just algorithms that can
optimize from data but they need views
on stuff they need views on the
political landscape economic cycles and
the like and I think you know they're
they're they're pretty safe for a while
as far as I can tell so Warren Buffett
yeah I'm not seeing you know a robo
Warren Buffett anytime so she'd give him
comfort last question if you could go
back to if there's a day in your life
you could relive because I made you
truly happy maybe you outside family boy
otherwise do you know what what day
would it be
what can you look back you remember just
being profoundly transformed in some way
or blissful I'll answer a slightly
different question which is like what's
a day in my life or my career that was
kind of a watershed moment I went
straight from undergrad to doctoral
studies and you know that's not at all a
typical and I'm also from an academic
family like my dad was a professor or my
uncle on his side as a professor both my
grandfather's were professors all kinds
of majors to philosophy yeah all over
the map yeah and I was a grad student
here just up the river at Harvard and
came to study with less valiant which
was a wonderful experience but you know
I remember my first year of graduate
school I was generally pretty unhappy
and I was unhappy because you know at
Berkeley as an undergraduate you know
yeah I studied a lot of math and
computer science but it was a huge
school first of all and I took a lot of
other courses as we've discussed I
started as an English major and took
history courses and art history classes
and had friends you know that did all
kinds of different things and you know
Harvard's a much smaller institution
than Berkeley and it's computer science
department especially at that time was
was a much smaller place than it is now
and I suddenly just felt very you know
like I'd gone from this very big world
to this highly specialized world and now
all of the classes I was taking were
computer science classes and I was only
in classes with math and computer
science people and so I was you know I
thought often in that first year of grad
school about whether I really wanted to
stick with it or not and you know I
thought like oh I could you know stop
with a masters I could go back
to the Bay Area into California and you
know this was from one of the early
periods where there was you know like
you could definitely get a relatively
good job paying job at one of the one of
the tech companies back you know that
were the the big tech companies back
then and so I distinctly remember like
kind of a late spring day when I was
kind of you know sitting in Boston
Common and kind of really just kind of
chewing over what I wanted to do with my
life and I realized like okay you know
and I think this is where my academic
background helped me a great deal I sort
of realized you know yeah you're not
having a great time right now this feels
really narrowing but you know that
you're here for research eventually and
to do something original and to try to
you know carve out a career where you
kind of you know choose what you want to
think about you know and have a great
deal of Independence and so you know at
that point I really didn't have any real
research experience yet I mean it was
trying to think about some problems with
very little success but but I knew that
like I I hadn't really tried to do the
thing that I knew I'd come to do and so
I thought you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick I'm gonna you know stick through
it for the summer and you know and and
and that was very formative because I
went from kind of contemplating quitting
to you know a year later it being very
clear to me I was going to finish
because I still had a ways to go but I
kind of started doing research it was
going well it was really interesting and
it was sort of a complete transformation
you know it's just that transition that
I think every doctoral student makes at
some point which is to sort of go from
being like a student of what's been done
before to doing you know your own thing
and figure out what makes you interested
in what your strengths and weaknesses
are as a researcher and once you know I
kind of made that decision on that
particular day at that particular moment
in Boston Common
you know the I'm glad I made that
decision and also just accepting the
painful nature of that journey yeah
exactly exactly and in that moment said
I'm gonna I'm gonna stick it out yeah
I'm gonna stick around for a while well
Michael looked up do you work for a long
time it's really
talk to you separation get back in touch
with you - and see how great you're
doing as well thank thanks a lot
appreciate
you